[Musik]
weit im westen mitten in den rocky
mountains
eine majestätische urlandschaft mit
klangvollem namen
die krone des kontinents
[Musik]
zwei staaten kanada und usa schützen das
herzstück dieser spektakulären wildnis
den ersten internationalen friedenspark
der erde
ein schutzgebiet inmitten einer
landschaft voller verlockende ressourcen
jetzt will ein mutiges team diesem
nationalpark vergrößern
um ihn zu retten
und es macht absolut sinn auch diese
landschaft zu schützen
sie starten eine expedition in ein
weltweit einzigartiges ökosystem
wir arbeiten hart damit artenvielfalt
eine zukunft hat
menschen die ihr leben der natur
verschrieben haben
ich werde keine ruhe geben bis der
friedenspark vergrößert ist
ein jahr in einer wildnis die uns das
leben auf der erde ganz neu sehen lässt
[Musik]
bei bitteren minus 15 grad geht es
hinein in die raue wildnis das gebiet
nördlich des nationalparks ist einsam
und ein idealer zufluchtsort für viele
wildtiere auch für die besonders schön
vielfraße jetzt im winter müssen die
tiere aus ihren verstecken kommen um zu
fressen
zwei hochspezialisierte biologen miriam
baretto aus der schweiz und ihr
kanadischer kollege tony clever wollen
herausfinden ob und wieviele vielfraße
hier dauerhaft außerhalb des
nationalparks leben
es ist eine exkursion in ein
einzigartiges ökosystem die sogenannte
krone des kontinents im herzen der rocky
mountains
mit 43.000 quadratkilometern fast so
groß wie dänemark
der kern dieser artenreichen gegend ist
geschützt im fast 4600 quadratkilometer
grossen zusammenschluss des
amerikanischen plaisier national parks
mit dem kanadischen waterton lakes park
reden über 70 säugetiere und rund 250
vogelarten nachgewiesen sind fast 1200
pflanzenarten miriam und toni haben
verfallen angebracht um herauszufinden
wie viele vielfraße sich nördlich des
parks wirklich tun
das sieht nach viel draußen aus schöne
dunkle haare
großartig
hier hatten wir bisher noch keinen
vielfraß zwölf kilometer entfernt war
mal einer das ist genau das was wir
brauchen genetisches material von viel
fraßen hier oben fantastisch
[Musik]
wo vielfraße leben muss das ökosystem
intakt sein
die marder ähnlichen raubtiere brauchen
große unberührte lebensräume im winter
sind sie großen säugetieren überlegen da
sie sich ihnen auf dem schnee fast
geräuschlos nähern können ohne
einzusinken ihre bevorzugte beute sind
dann schneehasen mäuse und eichhörnchen
um die viel fressen anzulocken haben
miriam und toni in drei meter höhe
gefrorene bieber befestigt die
fellbüschel der vielfraße funktionieren
wie ein ausweis haarwurzeln liefern
genügend dna material um im labor jetzt
erstmals festzustellen wie viele tiere
in dem gebiet leben und ob sie gesund
sind die nummer eins
mehr als zehn jahre an der drahtschlinge
die arbeit ist spannend hier seine
arbeit wie ich sie mache mit den vier
klassen die gibt's was nirgends auf der
welt und diese möglichkeiten solltet ihr
zu studieren und eine der ersten zu sein
die antworten findet nach den
berechnungen der wissenschaftler bitte
dieses gebiet einen lebensraum für rund
90 vielfraße für uns ist das hier ein
fehlendes puzzleteil wir wissen einiges
über die vielfraße in den nationalparks
im norden und auch im süden im player
und waterton national park dort werden
die tiere schon seit zehn jahren
beobachtet aber hier in diesem
unbekannten lebensraum dazwischen
da weiß man gar nichts bisher wurden
vielfraße nur innerhalb von
nationalparks untersucht foto fallen
sollen in den kommenden monaten
aufzeichnen wie die tiere hier in der
unerforschten wildnis leben
dieses einsame naturparadies ist das
derzeit meist umkämpfte gebiet
nordamerikas naturforscher wie miriam
und toni wollen es dringend in den
schutz des friedens parks integrieren
industrie und lobbyverbände wollen
zugriff auf bodenschätze holzbestand und
jagdgebiete
große zusammenhängende schutzgebiete
sind auf ein ziel von dem die black wie
träume
denn dort könnten ihre bison herden frei
umherstreifen die noch vor 150 jahren
der indianerstamm hat östlich des parks
in der prärie von montana seinen
siedlungsraum
in der nähe des ortes browning wo vor
zwei jahren der bison vertrag es den
stämmen des nordens ermöglichte wie der
büffel auf ihrem territorium anzusiedeln
und frei leben zu lassen wollen die
black feed heute eine ihrer herden
umsetzen
scherben carlsen leitet die aktion wir
müssen die tiere als erstes über den
highway bringen wir warten noch bis alle
da sind dann gibt es eine kleine
ansprache damit alle bescheid wissen
und dann geht's los die männer sind
stolz auf ihre schnell wachsende herde
als europäer die prärie besiedelten und
bisons fast ausrotteten war auch die
existenz der indianer bedroht harrie
boers der gewählte präsident des stammes
wir sind ein büffel volk seit tausenden
von jahren
bison sind von jeher unsere
lebensgrundlage essen kleidung schutz
auch unsere spiritualität brot auf ihn
die herde segnet uns alle
der geist der tiere sorgt dafür dass
meine familie gesund ist meine freunde
und alle anderen auch das liegt an der
art wie wir mit diesen starken tieren
umgehen ich tue alles was ich kann damit
es ihnen gut geht die stimme des nordens
haben ein visionäres ziel gemeinsam mit
den nationalpark aktivisten wollen sie
zusammenhängende lebensräume schaffen in
denen sich die tiere frei bewegen können
vom yellowstone-nationalpark in montana
bis zum kanadischen banff und weiter
nach norden in den yukon
hey ich brauche mir leute
ein dutzend männer und frauen auf
pferden und kurz sind nötig um die 600
bisons zusammenzuhalten und sicher über
den highway zu treiben
schon vor rund 6000 jahren haben
indianer in diesem gebiet bevor
getrieben und gejagt die kultur der
blackfoot ist legendär
wenn die indianer heute ihre tiere
treiben stärken sie damit auch die
jüngsten im stamm für eine
selbstbewusste zukunft das ist eine gute
erfahrung für die kinder
sie wissen zwar noch nicht viel aber sie
sind mit draußen und helfen in zukunft
werden sie eine echte hilfe sein
jetzt lernen sie die route auf der die
tiere wandern und daran werden sie sich
erinnern
genauso wie die büffel
die rückkehr der wilden wie sonst soll
ein beinahe verlorenes gleichgewicht
wieder herstellen
das öko system stabilisieren
artenvielfalt sichern
schon 1992 verabredete die
internationale konferenz zur
biodiversität in rio mehr land und see
fläche zu schützen
bis zum jahr 2020 soll jeder
unterzeichnen der staat 17 prozent
seiner landfläche unter schutz stellen
kanada ist bei rund neun prozent
das umstrittene gebiet im nordwesten des
friedens parks würde ottawa diesem ziel
näher bringen
dazu gehört auch der flathead river
die 400 kilometer lange lebensader der
gesamten region
im märz sobald auf dem flett kein eis
mehr treibt macht sich richards ökologie
professor an der university of montana
auf den weg mit seinem jungen
forscherteam will er untersuchen wie der
fluss den winter überstanden hat seine
sorge der flat wird immer wärmer
allein in den letzten 16 jahren stieg
die durchschnittliche wassertemperatur
um rund vier grad
dafür sinken die wasserstände weil große
schneemassen ausbleiben und das
schmelzwasser aus den bergen abnimmt
richard auer hat die allerkleinsten
lebewesen im visier
sie sind ein indiz wie es dem fluss geht
die biodiversität in dieser wildnis ist
erstaunlich dieser stein ist die ein
regelrechter jackpot übersät mit den
unterschiedlichsten wasserinsekten trotz
der erhöhten temperaturen findet richard
auer eine große bandbreite der kleinste
lebewesen
damit junge menschen das empfindliche
gleichgewicht der natur verstehen
verlangen die meisten us universitäten
dass ihre erstsemester ein umwelt
praktikum absolvieren
die 19 jährige wirtschaftsstudent in
ingrid roth begleitet richard auer seit
einigen wochen und würde gerne viel mehr
bewegen wenn wir unsere ressourcen bis
zum bitteren ende ausbeuten setzen wir
unsere zukunft aufs spiel
diese geschützten gebiete sind ja nicht
nur wunderschön und einzigartig
wir brauchen sie auch wir menschen und
alle mitgeschöpfe können ohne sie nicht
überleben der flat ist der am besten
erforschte kiesbett fluss der erde
niemals wurde er begradigt oder
verändert deshalb ist er für die
forscher der ur fluss schlechthin wild
und ungebremst fließt er dem flett legt
zu doch die unversehrtheit des flusses
ist in gefahr
energiekonzerne haben sein quellgebiet
im visier
es gibt bereits die anträge für zwei bis
dreihundert meter hohe staudämme ich
hoffe dass dies niemals stattfinden wird
aber die verlockung ist da man könnte
hier einen riesigen damm bauen alles
überfluten und den fluss in ein großes
hässliches wasserreservoir verwandeln
auch richard auer kämpft für die
erweiterung des friedens parks das
quellgebiet des flathead wäre dann
innerhalb der park grenzen und damit
unantastbar
[Musik]
direkt am north fork river einem zulauf
das flat liegt der kleine ort paul
bridge ein krämerladen zwei farmen eine
handvoll bewohner ein einsamer
sehnsuchtsort in den rocky mountains
auch für europäer oliver meister kommt
aus der nähe von schaffhausen seit fast
14 jahren betreibt er in der nähe von
paul bridge ein kleines hostel
vor 25 jahren kam er zum ersten mal
hierher
der gelernte werkzeugmechaniker wollte
eigentlich nach süd amerika auswandern
die rocky mountains lagen auf dem weg
und er blieb
wenn dies auf meine von den berg tg dass
sich kaum ein haus oder die straße sich
ja aber sonst sich nichts so relativ
unberührt dann habe hier alle möglichen
tiere die durch kommission kritisiert im
fluss filme sehen und wolf auf der
andere seite und bauen aber sehr ruhig
das gefällt man ja in der fluss zug
friert und erstmals wasser mehr
wenn es doch mal zu ruhig wird rumpelt
oliver mit seinem alten pick up ins dorf
gerade einmal 15 menschenleben weit
verstreut in und um paul bridge herum
besiegelt wurde die gegend erst ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts von pelz
händlern
[Musik]
zentrale für klatsch und tratsch ist der
marken teil eröffnet 1914 vier jahre
nach gründung des player national parks
[Musik]
seit kurzem versuchen katharina aus
tschechien und ihr kanadischer man neuen
schwung in den tante emma laden zu
bringen
dieser kuchen ist aus haferflocken und
erdnussbutter
sonst sind nur honig trockenfrüchte
bananen und reismehl drin also absolut
glutenfrei als oliver erstmals im
wildnis hostel übernachtete gehörte es
noch einem alten amerikaner
er arbeitete ein paar sommer bei ihm und
wanderte 2002 endgültig nach montana aus
um die herberge zu übernehmen
gucke dass du immer alles sache da heißt
sie brauchen könnte heißen soll wie opel
zu leben sondern arbeiten viel arbeit
sollte man feststellen fulltime job nur
her zu sein aber das macht ja spaß
man müsste was zu tun habe für mich ist
das immer so weiß nie wo die arbeit
aufhört und das spaß anfängt ich mache
das gern
die geschichte des friedens parks begann
damals wurde in kanada der waterton
lakes park gegründet 1910 eröffnete in
den usa
der glacier nationalpark auch auf druck
des kalifornischen naturalisten john
moore bald waren ist die rotarier in
montana wie einen zusammenschluss mit
den kanadiern anstrebten
1932 gründeten die regierungen in
washington dc und ottawa den weltweit
ersten grenzüberschreitenden
friedenspark zwischen zwei nationen
bis heute sind fast 170 schutzgebiete
diesem beispiel gefolgt
doch der vorreiter der bewegung ist
jetzt in gefahr
mai am highway nummer drei die straße
grenzt an das begehrte land dass
naturschützer in den friedenspark
integrieren wollen einer von ihnen ist
harvey lok aus genf in kanada der
rechtsanwalt gehört zu den weltweit
bekanntesten experten für die bewegung
der nationalpark video
[Musik]
er beobachtet mit sorge die
zerstörerische wirkung des highways auf
den friedenspark hier liegt der
wichtigste wander korridor für große
raubtiere in ganz nordamerika denn der
unterbrochen wird wegen zu viel verkehr
oder bauprojekten dann wird warteten
gleich scherze einer insel die tiere
wären abgeschnitten von den lebensräumen
und artgenossen im norden
[Musik]
die nationalpark aktivisten konnten die
unesco überzeugen die bedeutung dieses
ungeschützten gebietes zu untersuchen
das ergebnis 2010 wurde das verbot von
öl gas und kohle industrie verkündet
[Musik]
doch es muss noch mehr passieren denn
holz unternehmen nutzen wie gegen mit
ihren begehrten extrem gerade wachsenden
lodge sport1
freie geschlagene schneisen locken
geländewagen an die weitere zerstörung
anrichten
[Musik]
und es darf ohne einschränkung gejagt
werden
[Musik]
in fanny direkt am highway drei liegt
das hauptquartier des ältesten fischerei
und jagd looks von british columbia
[Musik]
seine mitglieder schätzen die wildnis
wegen des vielseitigen tierbestandes
[Musik]
vorsitzender des klubs ist mario rocker
ein strikter gegner der erweiterung des
friedens parks er und seine leute pochen
auf ihr jagdrecht und auf die tradition
[Musik]
die ein leben für hockey die anderen für
golf mein großvater war jäger mein vater
auch in unserer familie sind alle jäger
auch meine beiden söhne
das ist unser leben ohne die jagd wären
wir nichts für mario rocker und seine
waidmänner ist die gezielte jagd das
beste mittel um die tierbestände zu
kontrollieren
[Musik]
das ist ein wolf
die sind weit verbreitet in british
columbia aber schwer zu jagen
denn sie sind sehr scheu und das hier
ist ein deutscher
da gibt es nur sehr wenige im nordwesten
von gysi sie leben hauptsächlich in
alaska am yukon oder in den
nordwest-territorien diese weißen
burschen hier sind bergziegen und hier
wo ich meinen waffen kram mache da hängt
ein grizzlybär da musste ich schnell und
präzise schießen aber wie man sieht der
b hat verloren
eine wunderschöne einmalige trophäe
[Musik]
für männer wie mario rocker ist ein
größerer nationalpark eine idee der
regierung doch die ist weit weg und
kennt das leben der menschen hier nicht
glauben sie sie wollen so jagen wie sie
es immer getan haben
wir sind absolut dagegen
wir brauchen keinen vergrößerten park
das land ist für alle da für kohleabbau
und holzernte für die wirtschafts von
british columbia bringt es überhaupt
nichts noch größere teile des landes
zwischen yellowstone und yukon zu
schützen
im friedenspark sieht man das anders
hier gilt artenvielfalt als das
allerhöchste gut
im mai startet mitten im kanadischen
teil ein außergewöhnliches projekt
biologen wollen das öko system
wiederherstellen der friedenspark ist
einzigartig auch nach 1492 den beginn
der europäischen veränderung von
nordamerika nach christoph kolumbus sind
kaum tierarten und keine pflanzenart
ausgestorben
das gibt befüllt fast ausgerottet wurden
empört die welt weniger fürsprecher
haben kleine wesen mit großer wirkung
leopard frösche
kimberly pierson di-chef biologen des
parks will sie jetzt wieder ansiedeln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor ein paar wochen hat sie forscher aus
dem park in saskatchewan bekommen heute
sollen die kaulquappen freigelassen
werden
das ist ein wichtiger moment für die
frische und den park nun ist es an den
kaulquappen zu wachsen groß und stark zu
werden und sich in frösche zu verwandeln
hoffentlich kommen sie dann irgendwann
hierher zurück und legen selbst eier
damit ihre art überlebt wenn man sie
ganz genau anschaut sieht man dass sie
ziemlich dunkel sind und schon kleine
goldene flecken los geht's die kleinen
fröschlein die kleinen amphibien spielen
eine wichtige rolle als
nahrungsgrundlage für raubfische
schlangen und vögel
die wiederum sind beute für raubtiere
wie kojoten wölfe bären
wie sonst haben die nationalpark
biologen wieder erfolgreich angesiedelt
1952 kamen die ersten tiere aus dem
yellowstone park heute ist es eine
kleine herde von gerade einmal 13
befüllen
vor nicht allzu langer zeit treten hier
noch millionen von bisons im westen
nordamerikas gab es keine andere
säugetier rasse deren anzahl größerer
die ganze landschaft wurde geprägt durch
die büffel im begrenzten lebensraum des
nationalparks finden die bisons nicht
alles was sie brauchen
kim und denn helfen nach es gibt hier
keine natürlichen mineralien die die
tiere in freier wildbahn finden würden
damit es den würfeln gut geht müssen wir
diese salz lag steine im gehege
platzieren
drei stück nur in den sommermonaten
nationalpark spielen eine wichtige rolle
in der geschichte der bisons vor circa
500.000 jahren kamen erste büffel über
die beringstraße nach nordamerika sie
eroberten sich lebensräume bis weit in
den süden bis 1492 lebten sechs
millionen ureinwohner und rund 25
millionen büffel einträchtig zusammen
später dann die fatale jagt der europäer
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts wurden
jährlich mehr als eine million fälle
exportiert
nur 23 tiere überlebten im
yellowstone-nationalpark auch weil die
armee sie dort vor den jägern schützt
im januar grasen heute wieder mehr als
5500 tiere wild und frei wie einst und
sie bilden die basis für neue werden in
nationalparks in deren schutz sie sich
vermehren
heute leben etwa wieder 30.000 wilde
bisons auf den prärien des nordens
[Musik]
im hochsommer kommen die meisten der
jährlich rund zweieinhalb millionen
besucher in den park
[Musik]
auch ins entlegene paul bridge wagen
sich jetzt abenteurer aus aller welt
[Musik]
das hostel von oliver meister ist gut
besucht dienten ein stammgast reist
heute ab er lässt oliver ein paar
lebensmittel da es hier irgendwo die
fritz box so für leute die hierher
kommen mit rucksack oder fahrrad und
vielleicht nicht genügend zu essen dabei
habe die können sich hier helfe was
andere leute zu zurücklassen peanut
butter zurück sahen für instantkaffee
dienst enkel miles soll vor der abreise
noch etwas essen
magst du für sich gern wie viel willst
du die hälfte alles den ganzen vergiss
es ich möchte auch der neunjährige
meistertitel ist das dritte mal in
olivers herberge und ein ganz großer fan
ich bin mitten in der wildnis
hier kann man paddeln und man sieht
hirscher und wären
einmal waren wir auf einem ziemlich
großen fluss unterwegs und da stand ein
bär am ufer und ich dachte jetzt kommt
er rein und versucht einen fisch zu
fressen und dann sieht er uns und frisst
uns auch
[Musik]
miles ist mit seinem opa und dessen
freund rick einem pensionierten
chirurgen unterwegs seit 25 jahren kommt
oper den schon hierher
hier gibt es fast kein internet man muss
keine e mails checken man isst man liest
ich schlafe zehn stunden am tag stehe
aufmache frühstück und dann nichts
weiter
oder ich gehe in den wald oder auf den
fluss die zeit wird langsamer man wird
ruhig ganz anders als im rest der usa wo
alle immer in eile sind hier gibt es
keinen grund schnell irgendwo
hinzukommen denn man ist schon da es ist
gut für die seele an einem ort ohne
kommerz zu sein einfach am fluss sitzen
und die man fließen zu sehen wie mark
twain
es ist nicht mehr viel übrig vom
amerikanischen westen aber es gibt das
hier und das ist wunderbar
hallo wer bleibt schön da und frisst
mich nicht
auf dem trampelpfad zum fluss weiß man
nie wer einem begegnet
[Musik]
das ist so ein schöner platz ich will
gar nicht abreisen ich auch nicht aber
ich komme wieder nächstes jahr
schon nationalpark gründer john hughes
pries die heilende wirkung der wildnis
durch die kalten winde und die
kristallene wasser der berge kam ich ins
leben
im august geht im westen des parks der
kampf um das neue schutzgebiet weiter
der fluss experte richard auer braucht
ein aktuelles bild
gibt es illegale baustellen dicht am
flat besser sind verschmutzungen zu
erkennen die von außerhalb des parks in
den fluss gelangen
wie hoch ist der wasserstand jetzt im
hochsommer
[Musik]
der fluss und sein einzugsgebiet sind so
groß dass begreift man nicht wenn man am
ufer entlang wandert oder durchs tal
fährt nur aus der luft kann ich sehen
wie es dem fluss ergangen ist und was
die zukunft bringt
der fluss schneidet sich jedes jahr aufs
neue einen weg durchs tal
sein lauf verändert sich andauert so
bleibt das ökosystem der kiesbett fluss
aber in balance der wechsel von trocken-
fall und überflutung sorgt für ständige
erneuerung
es gibt nicht nur eine große vielfalt
von lebewesen im wasser sondern auch an
land und in der luft
vögel hirscher elche wölfe grizzlybären
thomas sie alle brauchen den fluss um zu
leben
[Musik]
richard auer nähert sich dem
empfindlichsten teil des flusses den
quellgebieten ungeschützten areal
die parkerweiterung ist für ihn ein
absolutes muss
die wasserqualität hängt direkt davon ab
wieviel landfläche geschützt ist das
wasser kommt aus diesem land in den
fluss dieses einzugsgebiet unter schutz
zu stellen und dem waterton player
friedenspark anzugliedern kommt nicht
nur dem fluss sondern dem gesamten
system zugute
das macht einfach sinn
den fluss schützen hieße also auch den
park selbst für die zukunft zu
stabilisieren
hw lok hat in den vergangenen monaten
eine expedition in das umkämpfte gebiet
vorbereitet er will mit einer kleinen
gruppe einen bergrücken erklimmen den
nur wenige menschen bisher betreten
haben es ist ein frischer augusttag am
leinheim krieg
tags zuvor haben sie sich im basislager
auf 1800 metern höhe getroffen
guten morgen das sieht nach einem
schönen tag aus
jetzt gibt es sind studenten biologen
und journalisten aus allen teilen
kanadas
sie wollen die wildnis kennenlernen
die an den friedenspark angegliedert
werden soll lasst uns aufbrechen leute
vor ihnen liegen jetzt fast 300
höhenmeter sie wollen hinauf bis auf
2100 metern vorbei an kristallklaren
seen und schroffen gipfeln deren
schneebedeckte zacken der krone des
kontinents ihren namen gab
mit dem ruf dieser wildnis einmal
gefolgt ist wird mehr davon schützen
wollen
davon sind die nationalpark aktivisten
überzeugt
nach zwei stunden erklimmt die gruppe
eine steilen bergwiesen dieser hang ist
ein gutes beispiel für die besondere
artenvielfalt der waterton lakes
flathead region bis hier her breiten
sich pflanzen aus dem süden der rocky
mountains aus und es kommen artige
pflanzen aus den kanadischen rockies so
weit südlich prärie kulturen schaffen es
aus dem westen auch bis hierher weil die
berge so flach sind und selbst pflanzen
aus dem nordwesten vom pazifik finden
bis in diese region
die wiese ist voller verschiedene arten
das rote ist ein indianer pinsel
hier ist ein vergissmeinnicht und das
ist jakobs greiskraut und da oben steht
deren gras mit seinen großen weißen
blüten das nördlich des flattert valley
nicht vorkommen
[Musik]
und dann der treppe die watt peak
mit seinen 2004 133 metern ist der berg
eine wasserscheide punkt der drei
weltmeere speist
über das missouri mississippi fluss
system fließt wasser in den golf von
mexiko
das ist kathrin river bringt wasser zum
arktischen ozean und über den columbia
river wird der pazifische ozean gespeist
was ist der mensch ohne tiere mahnte
1855 noah seattle der häuptling der
squamish indianer
wenn die tiere verschwinden dann stirbt
der mensch an geistiger einsamkeit
und was den tieren passiert geschieht
bald auch mit den menschen denn alles
hängt zusammen
[Musik]
kimberly pierson ist nervös an diesem
tag ende august mitten im kanadischen
teil des nationalparks
[Musik]
wenn wir heute frösche finden wäre
unsere ausbildung erfolgreich gewesen
dann hätten es die kaulquappen geschafft
und sich zu baby frischen entwickelt ich
bin gespannt
kim hatte die kaulquappen in einem fünf
kilometer entfernten sumpfgebiet
ausgesetzt doch wie viele haben es bis
hierher geschafft
da ist einer ein leopard frosch das ist
der beweis dass unsere anstrengungen
nötig war
da sind bestimmt auch noch andere
entlang des flussufers ich suche mal
weiter wie viele es ungefähr geschafft
haben
ein wichtiger erfolg für kim sie hat den
leopard frosch in den friedenspark
zurückgebracht und dem biologischen
kreislauf einen fehlenden baustein
zurückgegeben
ich hab ihn
was für ein schöner frosch er hat
hübsche weiße streifen auf dem rücken
und dunkle leoparden flecken mit hellen
umrandung
er sieht aus wie ein gesunder kleiner
frosch kim hofft dass viele ihrer
kleinen sprösslinge die nächsten zwei
jahre überleben denn erst dann können
sie eier legen und den erhalt ihrer art
wirklich garantieren
fressfeinde gibt es viele
weißkopfseeadler zum beispiel
sie finden im rotteten gleicher
friedenspark einen sicheren rückzugsort
zum brüten in den 1960 er jahren als die
bestände des us-amerikanischen
wappenvogel stark gefährdet waren
überlebten die tiere vor allem im schutz
der national parks
das expeditionsteam ist kurz vor dem
ziel
[Musik]
schaut euch diesen ausblick an fast vier
stunden sind sie durchs unterholz
geklettert nun stehen sie auf dem gipfel
wir schauen hier genau auf das fehlende
tortenstück dass wir dem waterton lakes
friedenspark an liedern wollen ein
gebiet von fast 45.000 hektar dass ich
über diese gesamte landschaft bis runter
zum fluss erstreckt
eine traumhafte stunde keiner mag sich
vorstellen was passiert wenn die
industrie hier einzug hält
diese landschaft ist über ewige zeiten
entstanden
jetzt musste ich erst so alt werden bis
sich diese wunderschöne wildnis endlich
erleben kann
mir ist das richtig peinlich wenn ich an
die situation in british columbia denke
ich komme aus victoria dem
regierungssitz
da fehlt es an politischem willen und
politischer lenkung
die wanderer sind sich einig politiker
und entscheider müssen diese tour machen
diese wildnis erleben zwei tage hier
draußen und man sieht die welt ganz neu
[Musik]
für harfe lockt der im banff
nationalpark aufwuchs ist das auch eine
frage des respekts
[Musik]
ich mag es in landschaften zu sein in
denen ich nicht zur herrschenden gattung
gehöre wo ich gefressen werden könnte wo
es grizzlybären gibt löwen oder tiger
sie machen mich demütig und erinnern
mich daran dass wir menschen nur eine
spezies unter vielen sind und die welt
mit allen anderen lebewesen teilen
müssen
im basislager planen sie die nächsten
schritte zeitungsartikel und fotos
veröffentlichen
petitionen nach ottawa und victoria
schicken hingehen und politiker bewegen
zu wandern und zu handeln
oktober in cam ward licht des friedens
parks hier haben die biologen ihr
hauptquartier miriam baretto analysiert
jetzt die informationen die sie im labor
aus dem fell proben der vielfraße
gewinnen konnte auch die fotofallen
haben viele bilder geliefert
doch die ergebnisse sind
besorgniserregend und miriam arndt die
gründe
dadurch dass in diesem gebiet von den
rund 20 viel holzschlag stattfindet und
dass viele frauen im winter statt dh die
straßen werden gepflügt bis tief in die
berge rein und sobald die straßen offen
sind kann nach die fallensteller einfach
herein und alle möglichen anderen leute
mit schneemobilen und sonstigen
maschinen und die viel klasse die
reagieren da ziemlich empfindlich auf
störungen
die biologen konnten viel weniger tiere
nachweisen als sie erwartet hatten
ihre untersuchung war pionierarbeit 162
foto und haar fallen
ein drittel aller fotoapparate hat
bilder geliefert
fast 2500 haarproben konnten sie sammeln
das ergebnis auch außerhalb des friedens
parks leben tatsächlich vielfraße doch
statt der möglichen 90 tiere konnten sie
gerade einmal 15 ausmachen
das braucht große zusammenhängende
gebiete gerade für diese tiere die viel
raum brauchen aber so herzstücke wie
orten packt und hoffentlich der neue
freizeitpark der hoffentlich irgendwann
realität wird das sind das sind wichtige
herzstücke um von dort können all die
verschiedenen tiere und pflanzen sich
auch dann wieder ausbreiten und
hoffentlich gebiete zurückgeben die sie
verloren haben
[Musik]
der neue status als teil des friedens
parks wird im nordwesten die holzernte
das befahren und die jagd sofort
verbieten
am highway drei würden mit unter- und
überführungen die wanderkorridore der
wildtiere wieder verbunden
[Musik]
ende oktober im kanadischen waterloo
village
[Musik]
event armes der superintendent des
nationalparks hat sich mit havok
verabredet es gibt gute nachrichten aus
victoria der hauptstadt von british
columbia
offensichtlich hat der druck von harveys
expeditionsteam gewirkt dazu die
alarmierenden berichte der biologen
ranger und fluss forscher klar ist die
vergrößerung des friedens parks kann das
ökosystem krone des kontinents retten
und darüber hinaus als starkes signal
zeigen dass kanada dabei ist die
versprochenen 17% schutzgebiete bis 2020
zu erreichen
es hätte natürlich eine wichtige wirkung
wenn das fehlende gebiet teil des parks
werden würde
die kanadische regierung befürworte das
jetzt es ist nun an der landesregierung
von british columbia die nötigen
verhandlungen zu führen
für hv lok ist die parkerweiterung ein
wichtiger schritt zu einem noch größeren
ziehen
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass wir
mindestens die hälfte der erde schützen
sollten
und zwar mit nationalparks die
miteinander verbunden sind
die nennt sich natur braucht die hälfte
damit die erde überlebt das ist die
herausforderung für uns menschen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
[Musik]
nein